what do British prime minister Rishi
sunak foreign secretary David Cameron
and King Charles III have in common they
all took their own private jets to the
United Nations cop 28 climate conference
in Dubai and it seems a little
hypocritical three prominent figures
traveling from the same location can't
share a jet as they fly abroad to preach
about climate change a short trip on a
private jet produces more carbon than
the average person emits all year green
party co-leader Carla denier pointed out
and look this is not to knock private
jets because who wouldn't want to fly
private but I think I speak for most
people when I say we are tired of being
lectured about climate change by the
same politicians who buy mega mansions
on Martha's Vineyard while
fear-mongering about rising sea levels
we're fed up watching our elected
officials fly across the world to give
away billions in taxpayer dollars and
don't even get me started on Al gor's
inconvenient energy consumption if
politicians want to improve the
environment they should practice what
they preach and they can start by
turning these climate conferences into a
zoom meeting